welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this video were
breaking down season two of Kingdom the
long-awaited zombie horror follow up is
finally on Netflix and if you've been
left in the dark ah but the way things
ended then this is the video for you
throughout it we're gonna be breaking
down the main plot of the season and
discussing where things could be going
in the future there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch the show yet then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
to never miss a video and please drop a
like if you enjoy the content without
the way thank you for quickness now
let's get into a breakdown of Kingdom
okay so just a quick recap of the first
season to get you up to speed
last time the king of the kingdom was on
death's door and a mysterious plague
ravaged the land I soon turned to who
would be a successor and initially it
seemed like the Crown Prince Chang would
be a shoo-in
however the Queen was also apparently
pregnant and due to the Crown Prince
being of illegitimate birth her child
would become the heir should it be born
whilst the king was still alive the king
died and though it seemed like this men
are the crown prince would have sent to
the throne the Evil Queen and her father
senator Cho had other plans
using a rare herb but known as the
resurrection plant the Queen was able to
bring the king back from the dead and
she planned to keep him that way until
she had an heir in place as we theorized
in our last video the Queen had had a
miscarriage unless she'd been rounding
up pregnant women in the palace in the
hopes of taking their child there was a
mole within the crown prince's group and
to make matters worse the zombie king
had passed the disease onto others and
now the undead virus was spreading like
wildfire throughout the land the crown
prince saw this firsthand and season one
centred around him fighting off the
plague that was tearing things apart Cho
did whatever he could to kill Chang and
the first season ended with him sending
a Legion of the undead to a location
where he was making his stand
after some backstory to the herb season
two picks up almost immediately where
the first season ended with the Horde
storming the crown prince's forces I've
always viewed Kingdom as a classical
story and this is definitely exemplified
here in the first season many of the
rich characters hosted large banquets
whilst the Parral literally ate one
another
and here that aesthetic is continued
food is God and this message of the
needs of the many
our weighing the needs of the few plays
heavily into the finale though it wasn't
intentional in light of recent events
the show is almost metaphorically
depicting how people will try to do
whatever they can to survive even if it
means stealing all of the toilet paper
I mean rice stealing all of the rice to
me the poor and zombies represent people
at their base instincts fighting forever
they can whilst those in power are cool
calm and calculated there are several
examples of this in the six episode run
and ultimately the show states that on
the whole though humans tend to be
self-centered we are strongest when we
work together though the intro is laced
with subtext it's also just amazing to
watch and it's probably one of the best
openings to a season well ever
overwhelmed the forces retreat and we
discovered that not only is the Prince's
trusted advisor mu with the mole but
that the disease has also been used in
the past as part of biological warfare
we realize later in the season that the
sick and elderly were transformed into
the undead through the plant and used to
fend off the Japanese forces through
years prior once more this shows how the
higher-ups have little regard for the
frail and the show is eerily similar to
current events this is clearly an
aesthetic that has been prevalent
throughout history and Kingdom does a
fantastic job of reminding us white such
folly the prince realizes that he must
end the disease in the land no matter
what and with a skeleton crew he heads
out after show he has seen firsthand the
desperation of the people and realizes
that all the aspects of society rely on
every single element to co-exist small
cogs allow the big ones to spin and so
on and there really is in one element
more important than the other and this
Aztec means that when we do lose
characters you feel the impact that much
more the show does a phenomenal job with
its pacing and it's easily one of the
best things that Netflix has put out in
the past year Kingdom really hits the
ground running and doesn't let up and
because of this it's an incredible ride
from start to finish
upon arriving among young Tsung which
I'm definitely pronouncing wrong the
group are ambushed and the crown prince
comes face to face with his zombified
father in an arena of chosen
making choke ilds one of the royal
generals named Anne who attempted to
expose the truth of the undead King he
shot when removing the barricade that
has the king and Prince locked in
together and this comes at a crucial
moment the king the heads his father in
front of an audience and is therefore
denounced as a traitor the news of the
King's death travels throughout the land
and the Queen makes her play however the
Prince and Coe have a plan in which they
use the resurrection plan to bring Ann
back to life and this brings light to
the lies an attacks show directly after
blood from a soldier has splashed upon
him and finally the armies of CHO
realized that the prince was telling the
truth
Sebby i whose name i'm also definitely
butchering leaves the area with joe as
she's attempting to keep him alive in
order to study the disease
aided by mu we learned the reason for
his betrayal as we learned in season 1
his wife was pregnant and she was taken
to the palace and captain of the guard
of the Queen mu was told to keep a
watchful eye over the Prince and report
back on his moves and it was insinuate
that harm would come to his wife if he
didn't Joe is reclaimed by his forces mu
is murdered and in the same moment his
child is taken from his wife and
pronounced the heir
it's a massive gut punch for the
midpoint of the season and I really
appreciated the expertly crafted writing
here and it was brilliant watching seeds
that were planted in the first season
come to fruition
Sebby eye discovers that the
resurrection plant actually produces a
parasite that causes the undead to rise
and that by exposing them to water they
will die similar to cordyceps they
operate by entering a host changing
their behavior and then infecting others
in real life this fungi grows in the
larvae of insects and passes on this way
however in the show it's in a rare plant
the eggs of the worm grow on the stem of
the Resurrection plant and once injected
they bring the bearer back to life upon
death through this method CBI manages to
save Cho but he rises even more focused
on the quest for power Cho pretty much
shuts down the investigation on his
daughter's pregnancy but suspecting that
a Hezbollah dt2 it he forces CBI to
examine her I think Cho even realizes
the monster that he is created and
seeing someone who reflects his tyranny
is as horrifying for the character as
the undead are to the kingdom the Queen
knew that this would be the case though
and she poisons her father killing him
in one of the biggest twists of the
season what I loved about this is that
show had been such an incredible villain
over the course of Kingdom that when it
looked like he was going to die I was so
glad that his comeuppance had finally
come
however after he was saved I felt like
the characters rule was never going to
come to an end
seeing him saved and then taken out by
his own daughter it's a really fitting
end for the villain and it's set the
stakes for just how he will that the
Queen really was the plague is listed as
the cause of his death and Serbia is
taken prisoner and forced to study up
further so that the Queen can build a
new army now the season ends with the
crown prince gathering his forces to
take down the Queen who now sits upon
the throne The ministers assembled to
oust her and it's a really triumphant
moment in which the crown prince shows
that through all that he is experienced
he understands the type of leadership
that the country needs now whilst all of
this political back-and-forth has been
going on you've probably forgotten about
the undead but they make a big bad
return for the finale
they were unleashed in the Queen's
palace for the final battle and it
really ups the tension things are as
frantic as ever and it's the perfect way
to close out the season the crown
prince's forces actually managed to
defeat them by using the like around the
kingdom which is now frozen through
breaking the ice they are able to dump
the entire head into the water and thus
kill the parasites though moose child
the apparent heir is bitten savvy I
managed to save him by placing him in
water this similar to a baptism also has
a lot of meaning metaphorically to me
and not only symbolize the cleansing of
the disease but also the cleansing of
the dark influences that he would have
had from the queen who perishes during
the episode after surviving the
onslaught the crown prince finally has
the throne and he's advised to kill a
child due to very few people knowing
about it
however he spares the boy states that he
is to be pronounced dead due to the war
and instead lets him take the position
now one of the big reasons that he did
this is because of his loyalty to MU
though he was sent as a mole he still
stood side by side with the prince and
saw the things that he did and thus he
does not kill the baby he also believes
that because the child is an innocent
who was not seen the horrors of the
plague that he will be able to be guided
on the right path far away from the evil
influence of what would have been his
mother and grandfather
the fact that many people believe the
baby to be at show also means that the
throne will not be contested many people
are still loyal to the Cho clan and the
Prince knows that if he took the
position than they would rebel against
him this could throw the country into a
further state of war and in order to
avert this he allows the light to
continue for the many lives that it
would save we get a time jump of seven
years and the country has stabilized
with the memory of the incident sealed
off the king is filling his new role
well however we discovered that the
infection did not fully leave him and
that a parasite still exists within his
body thus if he dies the infection will
spread much in the same way that it did
from the prior king he can also
potentially pass it on to his heirs and
it may exist in the kingdom for the
foreseeable future how things will go we
don't know for definite as the disease
constantly mutates and how it will lie
within the young boy is a complete
mystery elsewhere in the land we catch
up with the prince with CBI in Yongsan
that three travel to the epicenter of
where the resurrection plant grew on
this trail they discovered a man
planting them who stated that his son
brought it back from China the pair had
tried to sell the plan as a cure for
death but no one believed them and thus
the business didn't take off someone had
sold the plan to them given them
instructions well aware that it would
end up ravaging the land now what this
could mean as that is a conspiracy to
take the country down the way that I
took the ending was that a rival country
wished to ravage the land and thus
they'd been selling the seeds in the
hopes of doing this we learn that the
crown prince and ko have traveled to the
ham Yong province and they come across a
deserted village in which the plant
grows and they also stumble across an
infected person that has a belt tied
around their ankle the season ends with
them finding a woman who has the undead
in boxes and is dressed like a sailor
now by the looks of it she's been
bringing over the infected to the
country and due to the nature of the
bells she is in control of them whether
she's an enemy or simply studying the
parasite we don't know yet however
coupled with the information from the
two that planted the herb we can guess
that there was a plan to overthrow the
young king and invade the country after
the initial plague didn't work and the
plan to distribute it by selling it as a
miracle cure failed whoever this is
could have been sent in to unleash the
undead dire
luckily and spread the worms the
old-fashioned way this would explain why
the village is deserted and why this
mysterious character is also dressed
this way with the creatures in
containers so to summarize it I do think
that there's a conspiracy to overthrow
the king and after two failed attempts
to destroy the kingdom internally
they've sent someone in to do it
firsthand whether this turns out to be
true we won't know for a while but
there's a lot of things to look forward
to and I can't wait to see what they
have in store for us with the third
season as I'm sure you can guess I
absolutely love Kingdom season two and
it gets an 8.5 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on Kingdom and what you took
from the ending make sure you comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please drop a thumbs up
you want something else to watch that
make sure you check out our breakdown of
what held cuoco from the outside a
really is we go over what inspired the
character and the creature itself so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more every month we
give away free movies to be worth
subscribed to the channel and this month
you can when the Star Wars Skywalker
saga box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video make sure you sub
with notifications on the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of April
and the set will be shipped out from
then - ever gets the prize it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next
take care peace
[Music]